this is the Audi r8 it's a highly
efficient and compelling car its engine
produces an astonishing 199 kW at 6,500
rpm a torque of 330 nm at 4000 rpm now
part of the reason that it's so
efficient and part of what makes us
human beings comparatively inefficient
is that this car has only one goal and
that goal is exceptionally clear it has
to go very fast down tarmac roads as a
general principle no machine can be
optimally efficient at more than one
thing a robot that has to both climb
stairs and make pancakes will be far
less efficient than two distinct
machines each of which can focus
exclusively on a single task the more
limited the goals the higher wants
chances of efficiency now unlike the
Audi sports car our brains are not
designed or evolved to be maximally
efficient at any one thing this amazing
cognitive and emotional machine is a
profound generalist it comes moderately
well equipped for a huge range of
possible activities to write a novel
Spearfish bring up a child drive very
fast up Fifth Avenue sit in a high-rise
office writing reports live in a hut in
New Guinea marry plot an assassination
live in an ice cave go into politics
stay single or expand a small business
into the Asia market now the price we
pay for being generalists is that we'll
be less good at any one of the many
activities we perform than someone who
did only one thing their whole life long
we might not be the very best at
inflating party balloons the house will
be a bit dirty we might be a bit late
for the meeting
will not be perfect patient and
interested dinner companions will mess
up the public presentation again someone
would probably be better than we are at
helping a child to paint this might be
quite depressing at moments perhaps late
at night as we look back across the day
but before we get too sad we should
realize that our less than completely
optimal performance is down to one very
understandable thing that we've chosen
breadth and variety over total focus and
narrow perfection and that's a very wise
choice focusing on one thing to the
exclusion of all others has its costs as
anyone who's ever spoken to an athlete
who trains 10 hours a day 10
to find out there's a cost to being the
human equivalent of a sports car
unfortunately our society has set up an
absurd idea that it will be possible to
do many things and do them all
completely well that's why we hear so
much talk about an elusive thing called
work/life balance a perfectly optimal
career and a perfectly optimal home life
this is a mad idea work-life balance is
impossible because everything worth
fighting for unbalanced is your life
we're not going to be at once the ideal
domestic chef child carer and CEO if
we're strung out across multiple roles
all will suffer but that's okay that
you're doing too much and none of it
without mistakes isn't a sign that your
life has gone wrong it's a sign of a
very wise and understandable position
that you've opted for imperfect variety
/ flawless focus
you